this video was sponsored by oculus rift
hey guys Helen here full disclosure
oculus came to us and said they were
fans of our work which was one really
flattering and two really awesome
because you know Jared and I love that
new tech anyway they asked if we had
anything smart to say about VR and since
VR has been in the media a ton lately
from the rise of ISA Kai's and anime
like sword art online and overlord to
smash hits like ready player one we
thought pretty excited even Rick and
Morty uses VR for one of our favorite
gags Roy kind of wasted your 30s though
with that whole bird watching phase
where's my wife Morty you were just
playing a game it's called Roy snap out
of it
now I know we here at wisecrack can get
pretty technical Vic but we wanted to
try out this thing called optimism if
science fiction is any indication the
mass exodus to virtual worlds is
inevitable but instead of jumping on the
prophecy train we're gonna talk about
some of the philosophical ramifications
of VR technology and how it can
revolutionize storytelling and
perspective and while we could view VR
as just another step in technology like
the jump from radio to film there seems
to be something more to it that's
something we think is a philosophical
concept called qualia welcome to this
wisecrack edition on the philosophy of
VR and yeah no spoilers ahead but before
we get into qualia we should say
something about storytelling there are a
million reasons why someone would tell a
story the muses told you too or the
absence told you too or the amphetamines
told you too but at the core of every
story is a single ask to inhabit a
character's perspective Roald Dahl
author of everyone's favorite book about
a greedy CEO exploiting immigrant labor
said it best in Matilda the books
transported Matilda into new worlds and
introduced her to amazing people who
lived exciting lives she went on old and
day sailing ships with Joseph Conrad she
went to Africa with Ernest Hemingway and
to India with Rudyard Kipling she
traveled all over the world while
sitting in her little room in an English
village by allowing us to inhabit the
mind and body of its characters
storytelling can challenge our
perspective and change our views but as
a
as these stories are traditional mediums
like literature and film stop a little
short when it comes to inhabited a
perspective whether we're living
vicariously through Frodo delivering the
ring to Mordor or the dude just trying
to get a drug back they pee on your rug
repeatedly we're always reminded of the
space between us and the characters John
Gardner in his book the art of fiction
calls this concept psychic distance or
basically how deep we are in the
characters head it's the difference
between reading the sentence he walked
to the store and he ambled to the store
wild thoughts racing on his mind
the latter example brings us closer but
regardless of how the story is told we
can never collapse the psychic distance
to zero while staring at the pages in a
book or at a TV on the wall will
inevitably notice that these thoughts
and feelings aren't our own and as it
turns out there's a good philosophical
reason why this distance can never be
fully closed this concept called qualia
in philosophy qualia is the idea that
mental states like perception sensation
thoughts and emotions all have a certain
subjective feeling to them when you sip
wine or stare at the sunset these
experiences are all unique to you in
that moment the key word here is unique
your friend could do all the same things
and still have a different experience
and you wouldn't ever be able to really
explain this difference either as
philosopher Thomas Nagel explained in
his paper what is it like to be a bat we
could know everything there is to know
about bats but that doesn't translate to
knowing what it's like to be flapping
about and navigating the sound and
that's the weird thing about this whole
qualia debate there's an explanatory gap
between knowledge and experience one
that has some pretty big philosophical
and everyday consequences for
philosophers who believe that the world
can be explained by laws in science they
now have to explain this new type of
knowledge seemingly unrelated to facts
and for everyone else we're doomed to
tell funny stories about things that
happened fail and then fall back on the
old you should have been their defense
the big takeaway is that this gap
between knowledge and experience is real
and no matter how many words we write on
a page or how many flashing images we
have on a screen we can never bridge
that well maybe not never so what does
that have to do with VR well the reason
why
vr is so groundbreaking or in ortiz case
mind-bending I'm Morty you're Rick is
because VR gets us infinitely closer to
bridging that gap
unlike reading a book or watching TV VR
is an embodied experience you're right
there in the story
sometimes inhabiting the body of your
favorite characters this not only
drastically reduces the psychic distance
gardener talked about but it also deals
with the pesky qualia problem can't
adequately explain how great your
vacation was to your friends well let
them experience it themselves by
throwing a headset on them and we can't
emphasize this enough the difference
between knowing something and
experiencing something is huge
it's why you can feel somewhat safe
watching the ring on TV but crap your
pants the 360 experience combined VR
with haptic feedback in full-body motion
tracking and you can easily be fully
immersed for hours now before we move on
as I mentioned this video is sponsored
by oculus rift if you're looking to dive
into new worlds it's available for only
399 if you've ever wanted to be a
rage-filled green giant or a SAS field
trash panda you can save the world in
marvel powers United VR or if you've
ever wanted to get your tabletop
strategy game on and don't have hundreds
of hours to build intricate landscapes
there's Brass tactics which looks so
cool there's also the story driven lone
echo and the robotic mayhem of Echo
Arena and they're all exclusive if you
want to see me try out the oculus rift
for myself stick around to the end of
the video now back to the philosophy
okay I know what you're thinking Helen
even if VR allows you to sit behind the
eyes of your favorite characters that
experience is still subjective and
unique to you multiple friends could
watch the same 360 film or play the same
VR game and they would still all have
different experiences we haven't fully
bridged cuales explanatory gap and while
that's definitely true VR actively tries
to combat this at comic-con we caught up
with Ian Forrester CEO of the art
Playhouse whose team had just created a
VR experience for the show mr. Mercedes
when asked about the explanatory gap he
told us how good VR tries to bridge it
in trying to create a fully immersive
experience there needs to be a palate
cleanser almost it's what we refer to as
onboarding uru we get that but now
you're going to assume a different role
and different circumstance
boarding is essentially a tutorial
section in a VR experience it tells you
about the character you're inhabiting
and how to interact with the VR world
around you in doing so onboarding
combats the explanatory gaps by asking
you to forget well yourself
it's kind of like the suspension of
disbelief in theater except instead of
asking us to forget the stage the
curtains the not very convincing set
it's asking us to forget our actual
selves so how effectively can VR Bridge
quali as explanatory gap stripping us of
us and making us assume a new identity
the short answer is pretty damn well
recent studies have shown some science
fiction level results for example in one
study when white subjects inhabited a
black virtual avatar they actually
exhibit noticeably less racial bias than
those who didn't in another experiment
when adults were placed in a virtual
child's body they started exhibiting
more childlike behaviors according to
philosopher Frederick David Wong our
sense of self is deeply entangled with
the body we inhabit partly because our
body is the only thing we both perceive
and perceive with it's a bit like acting
we notice our costume and we start
adjusting our attitudes accordingly and
while we might not fully be able to know
a hundred percent was like to be another
person VR can get us close it's exactly
via ours ability to almost inhabit other
subjective experiences that makes it
right for new therapy techniques Freud
me for example puts patients in a motion
capture suit and a VR headset when the
program starts patients find themselves
in a VR replica of their own body moving
exactly in sync with their real-life
body they then tell a silent dr. Freud
across the room about their problems
after they're done users then inhabit
the body of dr. Freud and hear their own
problems from this outside perspective
before offering solutions to themselves
the results are pretty crazy with
patients reportedly experiencing greatly
improved moods after undergoing VR
therapy all because patients were able
to step outside of their own bodies and
it's not just virtual she attacks with
Freud that are seeing great results in
VR therapy things like exposure therapy
or helping patients conquer certain
fears and phobias by facing them have
huge success rates in VR in one study VR
exposure there
we had over a 90 percent success rate in
treating the fear flying which seems
better than the popular Papa's annex and
down a bottled line approach by buckling
patients into a new perspective it gives
them a safer way to face their fears
while some might consider VR a form of
escape from reality we can also see how
it can give us an entirely new
perspective on the very not fictional
world so what does the future of VR hold
well we may be a long way off from a
full ready player one but with computers
getting stronger and wireless headsets
coming out we're making progress
and while we as a society sometimes
indulge in fear-mongering about future
tech from Skynet Matrix VR has the
potential to make a really positive
impact did you know there are guys who
actually love heavy 360 cameras around
mountain trails and just so people who
can't hike them can still experience
them and yeah we might be scared of
creating some ready player one escapist
nightmare but a social philosopher Ernst
Bloch argued daydreaming and escapism
actually can positively influence
society by exploring the possibilities
of how things could be different we
engage in an immature but honest
substitute for revolution one that can
bring about much needed change a society
today all right I want to check out this
oculus rift and see what it's all about
I also just want to say that without
sponsors like oculus rift many of our
episodes wouldn't even be possible so
thanks guys
now where's my headset at let's do this
here we go Karina
[Music]
all right
[Music]
there we go nice going
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
we'll know recalls incoming okay
[Music]
that was awesome yeah click the link in
the description below to get more info
on how you can get an oculus rift of
your own
you